[Musique]
dans le cadre de la nes de gaulle initié
par le président emmanuel macron le
département de la réunion a inauguré
l'exposition les voyages du général à la
réunion 1953 1959 au jardin de l'état
nous saluons l'oeuvre de quelqu'un qui a
été engagée engagé au service de la
nation française engagée pour que cette
nation rayonne dans tout sur tous les
continents du monde entier et la réunion
air française de l'océan indien ne peut
échapper à cette commémoration
parce que ici nous représentons plus
qu'ailleurs la france libre la france
libre avec cette jeunesse conquérante
avec cette population attachée aux
valeurs de la république de liberté
d'égalité et de fraternité
cette exposition photographique est
proposé en deux parties une première
série de photos retracent le premier
voyage du général sur l'île en 1953 en
tant que membre de l'opposition est en
quête de légitimité politique
la deuxième série de photos retracent
quant à elle la seconde visite du
général de gaulle sur l'île en 1959
cette fois ci en qualité de chef d'état
alors ces deux fonds familiaux pour
l'année 1953 du jour où jean paul ii
fonds privés
et déposé aux archives départementales
donc nous avons dû demander
l'autorisation à la famille pour pouvoir
représenter ces images sur le site du
jardin état est à la fois sur le web et
enfin un second fonds pour l'année 1959
le fonds andré albanie qui est conservée
chez la famille mais pour les cas nous
avons l'exclusivité de la diffusion sur
internet
cette exposition au jardin de l'état
visible dès à présent jusqu'au 30 juin
afin de permettre aux visiteurs
d'approfondir leur regard des qr codes
au bas des photos donnent accès à
l'exposition intégral
[Musique]